Dracula has been haunting the big screen
for decades and along the way audiences
have seen numerous interpretations of
character some more effective than
others in the mood for some
blood-sucking cinema since 1902 s voyage
don la lune filmmakers have been
shooting people into space but as both
characters and audiences of Dracula
3,000 know sometimes space bites the
movie follows a group of space salvagers
led by Captain van Helsing the team
encounters a derelict ship where they
find the former captain dead and
clutching a crucifix van Helsing and
friends soon learn why as they
encountered count or lock that are known
as Nosferatu this is where all the
running screaming and bleeding starts so
what the hell is a vampire
but while vampires in space are exciting
on their own
Dracula three thousand leaves audiences
with one the worst alien ripoffs and the
single worst Dracula movie unlike other
adaptations Verner Hertzog's Nosferatu
the vampyre was a direct adaptation of
the original and aesthetically breaks
for most modern room dishes instead of
perfectly slicked back hair in a red
cape Klaus Kinski's Count Orlok Don's
simple black garb a bald scalp pointed
ears dark under-eye circles and
rodent-like teeth Nosferatu the vampyre
is truly the stuff of nightmares
thanks to the directors singular
perspective and striking directorial I
3d cinema like locusts appears in cycles
in 2012
Dracula 3d premiered amidst the most
recent cycle of 3d chewing its way
through the industry but while Dracula
3ds release followed successful 3d
horror adventures like My Bloody
Valentine 3d cult director Dario
Argento's efforts seemed hell-bent on
eroding any audience faith in the
technology soap style camerawork
low-quality 3d and even lower quality
CGI results in a rough viewing
experience a handful of those present at
the premiere noted that the film walks
the line of so bad it's good
maybe someday audience perception will
tip it from bad to good
but for now Dracula 3d remains one of
the worst Dracula films ever made
Bela Lugosi's legacy lives on thanks in
large part to his utterly devastating
turn in the 1931 film Dracula regarded
by many is one of the best vampire films
of all time
Todd Browning's adaptation is almost
single-handedly responsible for the
vampire films audiences enjoy today
Lugosi was so adept at the part thanks
to his years of experience playing it on
stage though Universal Studios almost
didn't cast him thanks to the hands of
fate audiences were introduced to his
singular presence though the cast
outside of Lugosi is regarded as
mediocre the film boasts luscious
cinematography and has held together by
the sheer power of the Stars presence
Wes Craven's pioneering and typically
exquisite work as a writer director and
producer of slasher films like Nightmare
on Elm Street and scream earned him -
titled the master of horror but Kraven
also hitched his name to a few flops
with Dracula 2000 being the most
embarrassing example Dracula 2000 like
many films at the turn of the millennium
sought to pull a classic character into
the 21st century
while vampires typically live forever
Dracula probably would have been better
off dead
despite the absurd plot complete with a
time-traveling van Helsing critics were
forgiving of this corpse like revival of
Stoker's classics given Gerard Butler's
pretty decent rendition of Dracula
Hollywood determined to get maximum bang
for its buck sometimes we shot films and
different languages such as the case
with the Spanish version of the 1931
Dracula which is just as good if not
better than its English counterparts
where Todd Browning's film relied
heavily on its star power and
cinematography director George Melford
style was more visually dynamic the crew
also benefited from having the
english-language dailies to learn and
build from though it vanished for many
years a copy surfaced in the 1970s on
October 25th 2015 spanish-language
Dracula made its official debut as part
of a Turner Classic Movies TCM presents
series and redefined Dracula history
forever
she's life she's not for that - she's
Italian the fine line between horror and
comedy can be razor thin leading many
filmmakers enter the realm of parody
while a bad horror film can be funny
bad parody is usually just bad Mel
Brooks Dracula dead and loving it could
have been the spiritual successor to
Young Frankenstein most of the cast were
veterans of Hollywood comedy who should
have been more than capable of parroting
Lugosi's 1931 version but the
ingredients just didn't come together
thankfully Mel Brooks other films aren't
going anywhere
if you're looking for a good laugh other
than Lugosi the late Christopher Lee is
easily one of the best Dracula's of all
time like many of the other Dracula
films horror of Dracula largely adheres
to Bram Stoker's text but unlike many
others horror of Dracula's story lives
up to its stellar cast thanks to a
well-crafted script from Jimmy Sangster
director Terence Fisher creates the
requisite mood and the capable cast
flushes out the material beautifully
especially Peter Cushing who is arguably
the best film van Helsing to date horror
of Dracula established many of the
visual flourishes expected from a
vampire film prominent fangs glowing red
eyes and pre-made wooden stakes through
it all Lee loses charisma and terror in
equal measure which resulted in
typecasting for much of his career
unlike Lugosi Lee eventually broke from
Dracula and is remembered for his other
illustrious roles Dracula fans will be
forgiven for missing this lesser-known
production co-created by WGBH Boston and
BBC Wales but masterpiece theater should
be familiar to public television fans
having been responsible for some
incredible literary adaptations from a
production perspective
Dracula's pristine period settings
should make it an easy fit however this
Dracula takes a few creative liberties
such as omitting certain well-known
characters and introducing a more
explicit disease subplot the changes
though novel do more to alienate
literary fans than give the story new
life
for all the film struggles to find its
voice landing somewhere between typical
masterpiece artistry and popcorn flick
throw away all adaptations Oh a great
debt to the 1921 classic Nosferatu this
premiered Dracula film introduced the
character and vampire mythology to a
wider audience the great irony is that
Nosferatu had to pretend it wasn't a
Dracula film the story goes that Studio
co-founder Alvin growl commissioned
screenwriter Henrik Galan to pin a
production based on Bram Stoker's novel
but when the Stoker estate refused to
grant permission the script was reworked
to avoid copyright infringement it
didn't work and the studio filed for
bankruptcy soon after the film's release
all copies of the film were to be
destroyed by a court order but thanks to
international distribution
Nosferatu survived so has its ability to
linger hauntingly ageless Lee like
Dracula himself check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite horror
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you